Not doing anything that's substantially
different.
It's a lot of the same techniques you go
up on Capitol Hill,
you are trying to get journalists to
write things that are favorable to your
cause.
When they don't write things favorable,
you protest,
um,
you do the same things that the national
rifle association is.
You make sure that congressmen
understand that if they take positions
contrary to what you want,
you're going to try to steer campaign
contributions to the other side if at
all possible.
So the nature of the activities is
pretty similar to what other powerful
groups do as well.
You know,
why is social security a sacrosanct
third rail issue?
It's because the arp has a position of
that and they can organize their members
and so politician who suddenly steps up
and says,
you know,
I think social security audit be cut is
going to be in real trouble for doing
it.
So at what they're doing is not all that
different.
They are particularly good at it,
but they're not doing anything that's
illegitimate with one exception,
which is the tendency to smear anybody
who is critical of this relationship for
being antisemitic or being bigoted in
some way though what happened to Jimmy
Carter,
for example,
after he published his book Palestine
piece,
not a part that is a sort of classic
example of this where he was accused of
being a Nazi sympathizer accused of
being a Jew hater,
etc. Etc.
And this is a prEsident who had done as
much for israeli security as any
american president ever has.
That I think is not legitimate because
it gets in the way of a free and open
discourse,
which is really essential in a
democracy.
You could certAinly diminish the impact
of all special interest groups if you
could have a really radical campaign
finance reform in the United States.
it wouldn't end interest group politics,
but it would take some of the fuel out
of it and that I don't think is going to
happen in my lifetime because of course
that would get resisted by all special
interest groups.
not any particular one.
Um,
I think because there's nothing wrong
with any group of americans,
uh,
organizing to shape american foreign
policy in ways that they think are good
for the country.
Uh,
I don't favor putting any restrictions
or limits or saying that you guys can
organize.
You can't come up on capital hill
anymore and talk to congressmen.
I think anything like that would be very
anti american,
very anti-democratic.
What I hope happens,
and I hope our book it helps encourage
is that some of the organizations in a
sort of broad coalition,
which doesn't agree on everything by the
way,
that some of the more moderate groups
and more progressive become more
influential,
gain more supporters.
Um,
and similarly,
some of the more powerful groups now
thAt tend to be more hardline begin to
rethink their positions.
I would have no objection to there being
a very powerful pro Israel community in
the United States if I thought the
policies they were pushing for were
better for us and better for Israel as
well.
Um,
so I have no problem with there being
the lobby.
I just wish it were pushing for policies
that were smarter.